[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
jeudi 26 octobre voici le programme de
ce soir quelle réponse apporté après les
émeutes de l'été dernier cet après-midi
la première ministre a présenté une
série de solution devant les 500 mères
les plus touché par les violences
urbaines de fin juin et début juillet
parmi les communes présentes la verrière
demain matin Elisabeth born doit
également dévoiler d'autres mesures sur
la politique de la ville depuis
Chantelou les vignes il est composé d'au
moins 50 % de viande de volaille mais sa
recette officielle reste top secrè la
semaine dernière s'est déroulé la 5e
édition du concours du pâté de Houdan le
grand gagnant a été dévoilé ce lundi et
le jeudi comme d'habitude nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
evelines au programme de ce soir une
marche nocturne pour Halloween avec une
dégustation de la soupe des sorcières
une maison hantée ou encore une balade
sur les comptes et les Légendes
d'automne de quoi vous plongeer un peu
plus dans l'ambiance féérique
d'Halloween il collecte des fauteuils
roulants des béquilles ou encore des
lits électriques pour le Portugal ce
soir l'invité du 78 est le président de
l'association Pharma citoyen Mustapha
Larbaoui bonsoir bonsoir alors depuis
plusieurs mois Pharma citoyen étend son
activité au Portugal vous collectez du
matériel médical pour une commune de
13000 habitants ponté d'abarca je me
voilà l'acent n'est pas là mais
magnifiquement bien dit on en parlera
plus en détail en fin d'émission avec
nous également sur ce plateau une
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78
Gabrielle Gontier bonsoir bonsoir ma
vous allez nous présenter les idées de
sortie en fin d'émission mais avant on
va faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence ces informations
Gabrielle par la première ministre qui a
réuni cet après-midi les 500 mères les
plus touché par les émeutes urbaines de
cet été elles avaient été déclenchées
par le décès de Naël la première
ministre ellisabeth borne a échangé sur
différents sujets comme le soutien aux
familles la prévention de la délinquence
la justice des mineurs et la
responsabilité parentale tout ça en
présence des ministres Gérald Darmanin
Éric Dupon Moretti et et Aurore berger
ainsi que des élus yvelinois parmi eux
l'adjoint au maire de trappe la verrière
et les maire de Mantel jolie et
Chantelou lesévges parmi les
propositions de la mère justement
Catherine Arnou la qualité urbaine la
mobilité et la miseemp place d'emploi
aidé à noter vous l'avez dit Mathilde
qu'Élisabeth bande sera dans les
ivelines demain matin pour aborder la
politique de la ville et l'égalité des
chances on poursuit ces informations
avec une inquiétude dans les ivelines
sur l'eau potable oui les maires de la
Communauté Urbaine grandpis saéoise
estiment que 80 millions d'euros seront
nécessaires pour prévenir les risques de
pénurie et développer les réseaux de
production et de distribution d'ici 2030
le conseil communautaire a déjà versé 17
millions d'euros au maire
d'aubergenanville cette enveloppe elle
provient du budget général donc pas de
hausse de facture pour les habitants
l'objectif répondre aux nouveaux risques
comme les tensions sur les réseaux
hydrauliques ou les micropollyants la
région yvelinoise et le territoire
franilien le plus touché par le manque
d'eau potable et hier soir c'était les
grands débuts du basketteur Victor
wenbanama en NBA oui j'ai voulu trop en
faire je n'ai pas besoin de mettre
autant d'énergie en défense voici les
mots de l'ivelinois Victor wembaniama
après sa prestation mitigée contre les
Dallas mavriix pour ses grands début en
NBA le prodige originaire du chaîner
rancour a conu connu une soirée délicate
très vite handicapé par le nombre de
fautes le basketteur de 2,23 a une
feuille de statistique de 15 points 5
rebonds de passes deux interceptions un
contre en un peu plus de 20 minutes de
jeu prochain match c'est ce samedi 28
octobre contre les Huston Rockets et on
va prendre la direction de Bougival une
maison un peu particulière est à louer
oui celle de l'ancienne attaquante du
Paris sa-germain Neymar depuis son
départ du PSG à l'été 2023 pour l'Arabie
Saou dit sa somptueuse demeure de
Bougival est inhabitée et est
aujourd'hui à àoué pardon Mathilde pour
la modique somme de 20000 € par mois il
faudra en plus ajouter 40000 € de dépôt
de garantie alors si vous êtes intéressé
autour de la table la demeure de 780 m²
possède 9 chambres et 14 pièces sur 5
étages elle possède également une
piscine chauffée une cave à 20 un espace
home cinéma et une salle de sport la
star brésilienne Neymar y a vécu pendant
6 ans oui000 € c'est une certaine somme
c'est pas confirme suis intéressé hein
faut juste les payer oui il faut juste
les payer on termine par un point
circulation est-ce que ça va bien rouler
ce weekend dans les evelines cabriel et
bien il faudra prendre son mal en
patience hein du côté des départs ce
vendredi 27 octobre ce sera rouge en
région parisienne et orange dans le
reste de la France dans le sens des
retours Bison Futé voie vert le samedi
c'est un peu mieux ce sera orange dans
le sens des départs en région parisienne
et vert dans le sens des retours
dimanche tous les voyant sont Aubert et
bien merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78
news le 78 vous emmène à la découverte
d'une tradition evelinoise centenaire le
pâté de houdans il s'agit d'un pâté en
croûte de voleil qui a son propre
concours il est organisé chaque année
par la confrériie de la poule et du pâté
de houdans de la présentation des pièces
à la remise des prix grégoryie canalet
Aurélie lafel et Julien Leroi ont suivi
la 5e édition de ce
[Musique]
concours des pâtés aux formes
différentes richement décoré et parfois
fleuries pour cette 5e édition du
concours 17 réalisations espèrent
décrocher le titre final celui du
meilleur pâté de
cette spécialité evvelinoise est la
fierté ancestrale de la ville et de sa
confréie qui défend son histoire et les
règles de sa fabrication vous avez une
pâte à pâé hein d'accord et puis ensuite
vous utilisez la la la la volaille de de
Houdan hein c'est un pompon qui qui est
une volaille qui est qui est noire avec
des avec des points blancs dessus donc
ça c'est la particularité une vous
mettez pas il y a pas de foira dedans il
y a pas de truve dedans he il y a pas
ces produits qui sont des produits luxe
après c'est d'aller chercher avec la
volaille l'équilibre avec le gras
d'utiliser les foies aussi hein qui
amène aussi un goût très particulier
assez fort mais qu'il faut essayer de
maîtriser avec le sel le poivre c'est ça
la particularité du pâté de Oudan des
particularités qui sont notées selon des
critères précis le pâté est d'abord jugé
sur l'aspect visuel les pièces sont
présentées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entièr avant d'être découpé en tranch et
là encore rien de s'improvise une croûte
ça se coupe avec un couteauuss mais les
pâté en croûte généralement il y a un
apport du ité on peut pas donc il faut
un couteau extrêmement fin rigide les
tranches sont observées minutieusement
par trois juris qui départagent les
pièces dans les trois catégories du
concours professionnel apprentis et
particulier malgré la différence de
niveau entre les participants le cru
2023 semble de bonne qualité il y en a
des très très beaux avec des beaux
dessins il y en a un peu moins c'est
vraiment une belle prestation cette
année par rapport aux années précédentes
il y a vraiment que des beau puis vient
la dernière partie du concours ce que
vous attend z tous la dégustation et la
cuisson de la croûte ainsi que la
dégustation de l'ensemble de vos pâté
donc tout ce qui va être les saveurs en
bouche et cetera les saveurs sont-elles
harmonieuses il y a-t-il de la finesse
dans le goût des différents ingrédients
la crroûte est-elle suffisamment
craquante et sa cuisson homogène c'est
sur tous ces aspects que les jurés sont
attentifs et c'est là que les pâtées se
départagent vous avez deux produits dont
un qui arrive franchement tête et qui
donne envie de de de d'être dégusté sur
les produits il y a une certaine
maîtrise de
fabrication et ça se ressent parce que
je dirais que le produit en
sélectionnant les ces deux parties de la
pâte et de la farce ça fait un produit
homogène et tout à fait tout à fait
honorable donc c'est c'est ce côtélà on
ressent tout de suite le professionnel
qui a passé du temps à préparer à mettre
au point son produit une fois les
vainqueurs par catégorie départagés
quatre jurés se réunissent une dernière
fois pour désigner le Grand Prix
d'Honneur
3 jours plus tard le suspense est levé
les résultats du concours sont révélés
au restaurant la
poularde Vian et Lecoq enseignant
formateur à l'école Ferrandi se classe
premier dans la catégorie
professionnelle et remporte le Grand
Prix d'Honneur du concours du meilleur
pâté de Houdan son pâté est celui qui
représenta la lettre H dans la farce
c'est pour
moi une belle récompense d'un travail
qu'on a qu'on a mené depuis
quelques mois on a fait pas mal d'ESS
des choses positives des choses un peu
moins
et voilà derrière on a travailler sur
sur cette présentation un petit peu
originale pour mettre en avant la
volaille de c'était un pé qui
était
manifestement mieux présenté mieux
cuisin et et avait des carctérisques
intéress la catégorie apprentis c'est
Gaspar niquez en formation à l'école
Ferrandi qui s'impose j'ai appris que
que j'étais sélectionné pour le concours
il y a un peu moins de de mois de cela
les entraînem é très difficiles ma
réaction à ma victoire était d'abord un
soulagement et puis pu une grande fierté
après le lauréa dans la catégorie
particulier est Alexandre habitant de
versaill en tout cas les 17 participants
ont tous gagné sur un aspect ils
permettent de faire perdurer cette
longue tradition du pâté de houd
et ça donne l'eau à la bouche en tout
cas tout ça allez c'est l'heure à
présent de passer à notre page
[Musique]
loisir préparez-vous à trembler la
compagnie pixom lance son nouveau
spectacle immersif intitulé La maison
hantée Once Upon punk un univers
post-apocalyptique mystérieux et
angoissant installé dans une maison aux
brevvièr Julien Leroi a suivi les
équipes de la compagnie pixom en pleine
préparation
regardez alors ça y est tu les as oui j
vais attends on les superpose pas et on
se fait pas mal enlève tes doigts ok
c'est bon des décors angoissants
s'installent dans cette paisible maison
à quelques jours de la première les
équipes de la compagnie Pixum peaufinent
les derniers détails de ce cabinet de
curiosité dès vendredi 27 octobre sera
lancé le nouveau spectacle d'Halloween
la maison hantée oneon punk un univers
post-apocalyptique futuriste proche de
celui du film Mad Max avec une
esthétique végétale et donc résiste un
petit groupe de nécromanciens qui
eux-mêmes perdent des membres dans leur
dans leur petit groupe et trois d'entre
eux partent en quête d'un élément qui va
pouvoir de nouveau redorer la flamme un
petit peu de de l'imagination faire
renaître la création dans la tête des
des des êtres humains de toute créature
vivante et il tombe sur cette bâtisste
12 acteurs donnent vie à des personnages
haut en couleur trmec Amelia Hart ou
Atropos une représentation immersive et
participative où le visiteur déambule à
travers différents espaces chaque
comédien suit un canva narratif avec une
grande place laissée à l'improvisation
on est dans cette cettehorie cette envie
ce plaisir cette joie de de participer
quand même à un spectacle c'est très
excitant
infernal dans le bon sens du terme un un
délirant parce que voilà les les décors
sont phénomén
tout le monde met la main à la patte et
ça c'est super je vais placer ça sur le
le plafond et avec les petites alvéoles
que je vais venir bomber avec une bombe
dorée ça donnera une impression
d'alvéolle de ruche et de miel qui coule
4 techniciens 15 décorateurs et une
centaine de bénévoles un travail de
fourmis pour installer des dizaines de
milliers d'éléments récupérés et
revisiter d'un spectacle à l'autre une
démarche écoresponsable propre à l'ADN
de la compagnie on a un partenariat avec
la ressource
du perér en Eveline et grâce à eux on va
sourcer des matériaux qui a priori
partirai plutôt pour la Ben et donc on
les récupère on les retaple on les
valorise on en fait des objets de décor
on en fait des objets un peu magiques
qui ensuite pourront éventuellement
repartir dans le réseau ou continuer à à
avoir une vie en tant que décor
rendez-vous au mycélium de la commune
des brevvières jusqu'au 4 novembre pour
découvrir cette maison mystérieuse
perceuse marteau et sissoteuse les
équipes de pixom travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour vous faire vivre
cette expérience nocturne et
[Musique]
horrifique et on poursuit cette page
loisir Gabriel avec vos idées de
sortiese pour les vacances de la tousin
et on commence avec un match qui devrait
intéresser les amateurs de foot ce
weekend on vous en parlait hier oui on
commence avec un rendez-vous sportif
Mathilde le FC Versailles jouera à
domisile au stade montboron ce samedi 28
octobre à 14h30 les ivblinois
affronteront le FC fleur 91 pour un
match de Coupe de France une bonne
nouvelle pour les supporters qui depuis
la saison dernière n'avait assisté à
aucun match national sur le stade
versailla en raison on l'a dit hier
Mathilde des travaux d'éclairage des
places sont encore disponibles pour
assister à la rencontre sur le site
internet du club toujours en sport
Gabriel vous nous parlez d'une
exposition à montiné le Bretonneux
histoire sport et citoyenté voici la
thématique de l'exposition qui retrace
l'histoire du sport depuis les Jeux
Olympiques d'Athène en
1896 aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 trois lieux
sont dédiés à l'exposition selon les
période présenté dans les maisons de
quartiers Henry Matis André merau et
Louis Jouvet l'entrée est libre et
l'exposition se tient jusqu'au 10
novembre une bonne manière de préparer
les jeux dont une partie de l'histoire
s'écrira en 2024 sur le sol ivelinois
alors direction toiri à présent même si
la ville n'accueille pas les gios elle
accueille un événement presque aussi
grandiose presque aussi grandiose je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas les lumières
sauvages reviennent à toari dès le 29
octobre pour la 6e année consécutive
cette année encore les jardins se
métamorphosent pour vous offrir un
spectacle féérique nouveauté cette année
le labyrinthe sera illuminé vous pourrez
également découvrir les 2700
illuminations au travers un parcours
inédit de 2 km cette année c'est l'Asie
qui est mise à l'honneur vous y
trouverez donc temple Bouddha géant ou
encore une représentation de la jungle
asiatique et pour pourquoi ne pas
profiter des vacances pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir l'espace rouillé oui et
cette année pour la première fois le
parc accueille les visiteurs dans une
atmosphère magique et envoûtante où les
conttes et les légendes des esprits de
la forêt prennent vie au programme
spectacle et animation Brigitte
teinturier responsable marketing de
l'espace rouillé nous parle du lieu et
des animations voici l'interview Express
réalisée par Julien
[Musique]
Leroi
l'Espace Rambouillet c'est un parc
forestier animalier qui est dédié à à
tout ce qui est présenter l'écosystème
forestier ses animaux pour sensibiliser
le plus grand nombre à la biodiversité
et sa
préservation depuis qu'on a ouvert au
mois d'avril on a un petit train
électrique qui permet en fait aux jeunes
enfants et aux personnes qui ont des
difficultés pour se déplacer de
découvrir la forêt sauvage on a
euh la partie la forêt desmil écureuil
euh où là on va avoir la présentation
sur des trampolines géants qui sont
installés entre les
arbres on met en place un événement avec
des spectacles et des animations donc du
spectacle vivant avec de la pyrotechnie
on est vraiment sur une thématique qui
allie la magie le côté onyrique et
féérique on va avoir un dieux cel qui
arbore des boîes de serre qui va
rencontrer une Dade donc une une une
nymphe des des bois de la forêt on va
avoir des cavaliers de
[Musique]
lumière et à quelques jours d'Halloween
on termine Gabriel avec un rendez-vous
qui va nous mettre dans l'ambiance oui
encore un peu de patience Mathilde avant
le grand soir d'Halloween mais des
animations ont lieu dès maintenant
demain soir à Guy en cours une marche
nocturnne est organisée au programme
déambulation animation bal folk et
dégustation de la soupe des sorcières
les bénéfices de la soirée seront
intégralement reversé au Téléton à noter
également que les 30 et 31 octobrees des
ateliers de décoration et des ateliers
culinaire sont organisé pour bien
préparer votre fête et bien merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
idées de sorties c'est bientôt l'heure
de l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin nous devrions rester
au sec normalement le ciel sera nuageux
avec quelques éclaircis au niveau des
températures compté 11°g à rouillé 12 à
Houdan et versaill et 13 à Mantel jolie
demain après-midi la pluie va faire son
apparition côté température il fera
13°gr à rouiller 14 à oudans et
Versailles et 15 à monteljolie pour les
prévisions météo de ce weekend le temps
sera mitigé samedi Météo France prévoie
des averses tout au long de la journée
côté température il fera en moyenne 11°g
le matin et 14°g l'après-midi dimanche
pas de grand changement des averses tout
au long de la journée et au niveau des
températures il fera en moyenne 11°gr le
matin et 16°gr l'après-midi allez c'est
l'heure à présent de passer à l'invité
du
depuis plusieurs mois l'association
Pharma citoyen récolte du matériel
médical pour une commune de 13000
habitants au Portugal pour en parler
avec nous Mustapha Larbaoui le président
de l'association Pharma citoyen alors
avant de parler de cette initiative
Mustapha Larbaoui est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter l'association Pharma
citoyen en quelques mots en quelques
mots Pharma citoyen c'est donc le jeu de
mots avec pharmacie et citoyen c'est une
association qui a été créée en 2007
voilà donc l'idée c'est je suis
pharmacien je me considère comme
citoyen avant tout et donc ça a été
l'association des deux et je trouvais
que les gens étaient les gens venaient à
moi c'est le propre de de l'officine et
donc j'avais envie d'aller vers les
autres parce que ça a toujours été ma ma
passion l'associatif donc l'association
a été créée à ce moment-là tout
naturellement et l'association s s'est
développé surtout autour du club de
football à l'époque dont j'étais dont
j'étais président et on avait fait des
tonnes de choses essentiellement les
visites au musée pour le programme de
CM2 des enfants pendant plusieurs
presqueune décennie donc c'était plus
cet aspect là à l'époque et puis il y
avait également deux volets dont on
parlait peu à l'époque c'était le
matériel médical que que déjà à l'époque
on donnait à différentes
associations association marocaine
association sénégalaise on a eu des gens
de du Liban quand il y a eu des
événements il y a eu Madagascar quand il
y a eu également malheureus des des
malheurs c'est souvent c'est souvent
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on eston que nous
sommes sollicités et donc là vous vous
étendez au Portugal pourquoi alors tout
simplement parce que j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un dans le cadre du football donc
elle s'appelle
lordess de son prénom elle est dans le
football de la même façon donc on a
commencé à échanger sur ces notions
entre guillemets qu'on qu'on avait en
commun et puis je lui raconte l'histoire
de Pharm à citoyen et elle me dit écoute
ça ça pourrait intéresser également euh
une région euh comme le nord du Portugal
donc pant d' Barca comme vous l'aveiez
dit tout à l'heure et donc ben pourquoi
pas mais euh ce qui m'a intéressé
surtout c'est que d'abord j'avais un
contact direct euh et donc il
connaissait merveilleusement bien la la
région les les acteurs du du terrain et
deuxièmement ce qui m'intéressait c'est
de d'avoir le process en entier
c'est-à-dire que avant je récoltait du
matériel et on le donnait à des
associations et bien évidemment c'était
des intermédiaires et le le point final
je ne l'avais pas là vous YZ vousmême on
là voilà on est on est dans du BC si je
peux me permettre l'expression euh euh
c'est-à-dire on on on produit ce qu'on a
à faire et ça va directement chez le
client donc ça peut être des
particuliers des gens que que lourdess
connaît euh sur le territoire des
connaissances donc c'est vraiment des
gens qui en ont besoin et c'est en
direct si sinon il y a également des
associations qui sont sur place et qui
sont nos relais ou des municipalités
comme panta daamca qui au passage pour
vos téléspectateurs des clés sous bois
pon la Barca est une commune jumelée
avec les clés sous bois alors vous
apportez là-bas du matériel médical
c'était quoi les besoins là-bas alors
pour pour savoir on vit dans un pays où
le système social comme vous le savez il
y a une grosse prise en charge des
médicaments et au-delà des médicaments
jusqu'à le matériel médical il faut
savoir qu'au Portugal malheureusement ça
s'arrête à ce niveau-là donc ça veut
dire que toutes les personnes qui ont
besoin d'un d'un lit médicalisé de de
fauteuil roulant de chaise percé bref du
matériel le PAI et voilà donc ça coûte
très cher alors on fait pas concurrence
à des gens qui le vendent mais c'est des
gens qui l'auraient pas acheté parce que
pour certains et pour co ch làb trop
cher en fait ça coûte quasiment aussi
cher ici simplement faut en avoir les
moyens c'est dire que même ici en France
probablement que si cétait pas pris en
charge par la CQ beaucoup ne pourrait
pas se le permettre ici donc là-bas
c'est le même prix ils peuvent pas se le
permettre de la même façon puisque c'est
pas pris en charge donc là l'idée est
très simple j'ai mes intermédiaires en
fait d'une ancienne vie puisque je suis
j'ai été dans la distribution du
médicament et du matériel médical dans
dans mes entreprise à l'époque donc pour
pour les nommer serpan donc une
coopérative de pharmaciens matériel VI
et oxyam vient voilà oxyam filiale de
SERP et comme ce sont les entreprises
vertueuses coopérative de pharmaciens
ils sont à l'écoute finalement de ce
type de besoin parce que on est
complètement dans l'idée du recyclage
donc c'est vraiment vertueux puisque
l'idée c'est plutôt que de jeter le
matériel arrive en fin de vie en fin de
vie fiscale d'amortissement fiscal c'est
généralement à 90 % jeté à la ferraille
puisque on en a pas besoin il faut le
recycler le recycler malheureusement
c'est plus dans les hauts fourneaux donc
voilà donc l'idée c'est de récupérer du
matériel qui fonctionne j'insiste et en
très bon état il s'agit pas de ramener
de la ferraille par ailleurs et donc ce
matériel qui fonctionne bien qui est en
très bon état est acheminé donc par nos
soins et là on fait le process de A à Z
puisqu'on part directement chez
d'ailleurs le projet s'étend au-delà de
ponté d'abarca puisqueil y a d'autres
villages portugais qui en bénéficient
aussi voilà alors en fait c'est toujours
pareil hein c'est c'est pour moi ça
toujours été des aventures humaines donc
là c'est la rencontre avec lourd j'en ai
parlé tout àheure et aujourd'hui c'est
la rencontre avec tous les acteurs
locaux mais Pharma citoyen c'est pas
simplement du don pour donner Pharma
citoyen reçoit aussi parce que l'idée
c'est pas simplement de leur donner
parce qu'ils en ont besoin tout le monde
a besoin tout le monde pourrait avoir en
avoir besoin d'autres pays que j'ai cité
tout à l'heure mais farm citoyen c'est
aussi l'échange et donc par exemple le 5
octobre nous allons fêteré la
citoyenneté portugaise puisque nous
avons célébré le 5 octobre
1910 que probablement les
téléspectateurs ne connaissent pas mais
c'est l'avénement de la Première
République portugaise voilà et en même
temps c'est un clin d'œil pour moi à la
communauté portugaise que
j'apprécie vraiment vraiment depuis pour
moi c'est pas une découverte le
Portugais ça fait plus de 30 ans que j'y
vais donc là j'y retourne mais c'est un
pays fabuleux voilà j'invite tous les
téléspectateurs de tv78 à découvrir ce
pays s'ils le peuvent mais c'est
absolument fabuleux voilà de par leur
histoire de par leur culture de par leur
rapport leur rapport homme-femme le
rapport aux politique qui est beaucoup
plus apaisé et et surtout des paysages
fabuleux que ça soit le sud dans l'algar
que ça soit le Nord montagneux la mer
enfin voilà un très beau pays ce qui me
permet de de vivre une aventure humaine
et en même temps l'utile à l'agréable
c'est tellement beau et c'est tellement
on s'y sent tellement bien et l'objectif
c'est quoi quoi c'est de péréniser ces
collectes transport comment vous allez
faire alors l'idée c'est évidemment il y
a un cût puisque vous avez compris qu'il
fallait acheminer ce matériel donc il y
a un coût ce coût nous l'assumons sans
aucune subvention je je ne suis pas dans
les subventions d'État ou de
collectivité donc ça coûte rien à la
collectivité locale ni la collectivité
nationale par contre j'ai des
partenaires autour de moi qui trouvent
l'idée intéressante ça coûte rien aux
gens qui sont sur place donc mon travail
c'est de collecter le mat
et de collecter les fonds bien sûr et
moi j'y suis bien sûr à titre à titre
privé puisque j'investis dans ce projet
à titre personnel et vous chiffrez à
combien à peu près le nombre de matériel
que vous avez envoyé jusque jusque là
alors jusque là depuis le Portugal c'est
depuis le mois d'avril hein c'est
nouveau on les voit à l'antenne c'est
jusqu'à maintenant je crois que c'est 5
ou si voyages et c'est à chaque fois
entre TR et quatre lits on en voit un à
l'écran voyz en très bon ét pr beaucoup
de place du matin
un véhicule bon je vous fais je vous
passe les détails de la de la logistique
et du et du coût là c'était plutôt à
l'époque puisque par définition là
c'était le Sénégal mais voilà donc il y
a il y a une il y a un travail
évidemment de logistique mais l'idée
c'est évidemment de pérenniser et donc
d'avoir des partenaires qui vont nous
suivre sur le long terme et on compte
bien ne pas s'arrêter là et probablement
d'autres pays en Europe parce que ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de passer les
frontières
sans s'y arrêter et sans avoir à y être
taxé c'est beaucoup plus compliqué quand
on s'attaque par exemple à à des douanes
en Algérie Maroc Sénégal là c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué beaucoup plus
coûteux et là je passe par des
associations qui le font mais en Europe
c'est le déplacement qui m'intéresse
c'est les tableaux des paysages qui
défilent quand on y va donc je m'y
implique parce que c'est un vrai plaisir
d'y aller euh et donc comme je vous l'
dis tout à l'heure il y a un besoin on
répond à un besoin et puis c'est
tellement voilà c'est tellement
chaleureux enfin je je je veux pas vous
ennuyer avec tous les qualificatifs mais
c'est un vrai plaisir donc plein
d'autres projets à venir on aura
peut-être l'occasion de vous réin de
vous réinviter sur ce plateau merci pour
l'invitation je reviendrai mais surtout
pour la communauté portugaise également
que je connais depuis des décennies au
regard de mon âge communauté qui a
beaucoup participé beaucoup uvré pour ce
pays dont on parle peu je trouve et qui
a une contribution nation
dont on parle peu et pourtant voilà moi
je le rends hommage aussi au travers de
cette association en tous les cas au
travers de de ce que l'on fait dans nos
déplacements et bien merci beaucoup
Mustapha Larbaoui d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur
tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous